who lives who dies who returns to the
afterlife from whence they came and most
importantly who gets slimed this is the
ending of ghostbusters afterlife
explained obviously spoilers ahead
arguably the most important character in
ghostbusters afterlife is phoebe the
brilliant young granddaughter of egon
spengler it's phoebe who cracks open the
mystery at the heart of the film and
forms a connection across generations of
her estranged family in the process at
the beginning of the film phoebe is an
outsider not just in somerville but in
her own family by the end of the film
she's the heart of her extended new
family and friend group a hero to the
world and a newly minted ghostbuster
continuing the tradition set up by her
late grandfather we see bibi's journey
to self-actualization but the question
remains what happens to her next it's
easy to imagine her as the first junior
member of the ghostbusters attending a
fancy science-based new york city school
by day and wielding a proton pack by
night it's also easy to see her staying
in summerville for a while archiving and
continuing her grandfather's work as she
digs deeper into the mysteries of gozer
whatever happens phoebe has a bright
future not just because of what she's
achieved but because she's learned how
to really be herself
though his personal journey in the film
is considerably less developed than his
sisters trevor spengler still gets an
arc across ghostbusters afterlife though
he definitely considers himself the cool
one in his family trevor is still a bit
of an outsider thanks to his fresh
arrival in somerville by the end of the
film trevor has become a ghostbuster of
sorts alongside his sister despite his
lack of scientific knowledge or
particular enthusiasm for the paranormal
what he does have though is a sizable
sense of mechanical wisdom as evidenced
by his ability to fix ecto-1 with only a
tiny bit of supernatural help from his
grandfather it's easy to see him
sticking around somerville but it's just
as easy to see him moving to new york
city where trevor could become the
winston of the next generation of
ghostbusters
he's not a scientist but he's a hard
worker with a sharp mind and he's
willing to dig in deep for the people he
cares about
at the beginning of the film callie
spengler feels like a failed mother she
hasn't been able to make life in the
city work out her kids are growing and
changing in ways she doesn't fully
understand and her only refuge in life
is a broken down old house in the middle
of oklahoma left to her by a father who
never had time for
but like every other member of her
family over the course of the story cali
finds a new sense of purpose and
realizes the father she never really
knew not only cared about her but did
everything he could to protect her from
forces she couldn't understand at the
time a new sense of purpose also comes
through the arrival of gary gruberson
the local seismologist and teacher who
not only adores her but adores her kids
as well so what happens to them next
having made peace with their families
past callie seems ready to build a new
future with gary whether that's in
somerville new york city or somewhere
else entirely a new family unit has
grown out of the ashes of the old one
though much of the film centers on the
spengler family a good portion of the
plots and ghostbusters afterlife is
pushed forward by the kid known as
podcast phoebe's summer school friend
with a deep interest in mysteries and
other assorted occult lore though phoebe
brings the scientific know-how and
observational powers to the team podcast
brings the belief in the supernatural
that allows her to see what's right in
front of her and the research skills to
dig into what's really going on by the
end of the film it's clear that he's
basically the raymond stance of the new
ghostbusters team and rey himself makes
it clear that he's a fan of the young
podcaster obviously podcast's role in
what went down in oklahoma could mean a
big boost to his subscriber base
provided enough people know that
anything went down at all but it will
also mean his appetite for more
supernatural mysteries will only grow
with time
ghostbusters afterlife is largely set in
somerville oklahoma an out of the way
former mining town that's basically a
tiny dot on the map with seemingly
nothing to show for itself by the end of
the film though somerville has become
the epicenter of supernatural activity
on earth as the discovery of a temple
built by an eccentric architect to
summon an ancient sumerian god propels
the ghostbusters into a new adventure
after gozer was trapped by the team
things seemed poised to quiet down at
somerville and we see the old ecto-1 car
back in action in new york city but that
doesn't mean the oklahoma town won't get
any more attention if it truly did serve
as the force behind a supernatural
re-awakening it's bound to attract all
manner of investigators scientists
tourists and media podcasts won't be the
only person investigating its mysteries
anymore and that could both lead to good
and bad things from the town alleged
ghost sightings and related supernatural
occurrences have been reported across
the entire tri-state area in the
original ghostbusters the team faced
gozer as the ancient god took the form
of a giant representation of the stay
pup marshmallow man after crossing the
streams of their proton packs the
ghostbusters were able to defeat gozer's
destroyer form and thus banish the god
back to its own dimension seemingly for
good of course we now know that gozer
was just biting their time until they
could re-enter our dimension but
thankfully egon spangler had developed a
plan instead of just banishing the
creature yet again he built an elaborate
high-powered trap on his homestead in
oklahoma waiting for the moment that he
could lure gozer in and spring it it
didn't work for egon but his
granddaughter her family and friends and
the surviving original ghostbusters were
able to capture the creature the
question is if gozer now contained in a
trap what happens next there's a good
chance gozer will need to be busted at
least one more time
over the course of the film the mystery
at the heart of ghostbusters afterlife
is slowly unearthed often quite
literally eventually phoebe trevor
podcast and lucky discover a tombslash
temple complex beneath the mountain
built in tribute to gozer a sumerian god
who first appeared in the original
ghostbusters film the tomb is full of
interesting details but phoebe picks up
one in particular that stands out with
regard to the franchise's future a stone
relief that features carved dates of
various years in which major
catastrophes occurred what's especially
interesting about these carvings is that
there appears to be another partially
obscured date carved into the rock
sometime after 2021 it's difficult to
make out exactly when it is but gozer's
closest followers probably have some
idea and the presence of the temple in
oklahoma suggests there could be others
out there so what future catastrophe
awaits this next generation of
ghostbusters time will tell
ghostbusters afterlife is a movie packed
with cameo appearances though she was
confirmed to be a part of the film
months before its release one former
ghostbusters star waited until the very
end to show up dana barrett who
developed a romance with dr peter
venkman in the first film and rekindled
it in a second dana finally appears in a
mid-credits scene in the film that
echoes our first meeting with bankman
back in 1984 as she runs his old shock
treatment esp test on him there's clear
flirtation happening between the two of
them and bankman even throws out the
phrase true love at one point it's such
a brief scene that we don't get too many
clues but it's clear that the filmmakers
at least want us to think about what
might be happening perhaps an eventual
afterlife sequel could clear up just how
well peter and dana are getting along
these days
in one crucial scene in ghostbusters
afterlife bibi calls the old number in a
vintage ghostbusters commercial and is
connected to ray stance's a cult book
shop in new york city after a little
nudging she's able to get ready to tell
her a little of the backstory behind the
breakup of the ghostbusters according to
rey it had its roots in two things
egon's obsession with the re-emergence
of gozer and an almost complete lack of
new calls for supernatural assistance
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years gozer's return obviously shook at
least a few ghosts loose and at the very
end of the film we see ecto-1 back in
action but how many ghosts are there to
really bust gozer is after all in
captivity now and the portal that
awakened the god of destruction seems to
be dormant has something else shaken
loose that will guarantee continued work
for the team or are they just going to
do what they can with what they have for
as long as possible obviously a sequel
would help to clear this up quite a bit
in the post-credits scene of
ghostbusters afterlife winston zettamore
and janine melnitz meet new york city to
discuss the future of the ghostbusters
team winston's success in the world of
finance means that he has considerable
resources at his disposal enough to buy
back the firehouse restore ecto-1 and
get the team up and running again the
question remaining is what exactly that
team will look like once winston and
janine are all set up again will the
spangler family move back to new york
and be part of the next era of the
company with janine and winston running
the show behind the scenes it seems
likely that if winston and janine are
back in the game rey would have a hard
time not lurking around the firehouse
himself training new recruits and
venkman well he might not care for
busting anymore but even if he doesn't
he could be persuaded to handle the
marketing side of things it's easy to
imagine the crew coming together with
the spanglers to launch the next phase
of ghostbusters incorporated and perhaps
even do what previous sequel ideas had
in mind and franchise the whole thing
when locations in every major city
whatever the case the old firehouse is
about to power up again and that trap
grid in the basement might have a few
old terrors still lurking in it
though phoebe is the star of
ghostbusters afterlife you could make
the case that the most important
character in the overall story is
actually her deceased grandfather dr
egon spangler by the time of afterlife
egon is a ghost lurking in his house in
oklahoma and biding his time until his
genius granddaughter puts all the pieces
of his plant to defeat gozer together
while that happens we learned that
somewhere along the way he decided he
had to make a massive sacrifice in his
quest to keep the world safe from a dark
god when he couldn't convince his fellow
ghostbusters that gozer was about to
resurge egon instead cut himself off
from everyone with the exception of
janine moved to oklahoma to be near the
old gozer sites and abandoned both his
family and his friends for their own
protection do you have any hobbies
i collect spores molds and fungus
it's a move that speaks to his obsessive
nature but also to his ability to think
in terms of the greater good egon's
choices could easily be dismissed as
part of his character as the coldest
ghostbuster but it took an enormous
level of love and care for the people in
his life to do what he did it was a
sacrifice that the film only scratched
the surface of but in the end it proved
that egon spangler may have had the
biggest heart of all of the ghostbusters
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]